bonsoir giorgelli merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors cet
article on l'a compris accuse
directement nommément le président
poutine au moment où les etats-unis et
la russie opère un rapprochement dans
cette crise du coronavirus avec une
soeur geste humanitaire de part et
d'autre hasard du calendrier c'est un
joueur unique c'est de trouver comment
la russie et l apparition du comment des
virus il s'agissait que d'une question
de temps jusqu'à ce qu'on réussisse à
blâmer la russie peut pas vraiment
reproché à la russie le canton à virus
tels que les gens commençaient à se
demander quel angle d attaque trouver
une autre est ingénieuse qui pourrait
faire de la russie les véritables
coupables du cornât virus tente le new
york times a trouvé cette approche se
serrer des trolls et russe
donc l'on considère comme les
porte-parole du président soutient bien
sûr qu'ils auraient produit cette idée
ridicule
donc ce sont eux qu'il faut blâmer pour
cette pandémie
alors sur quoi parce qu'on a du mal a
effectivement à comprendre sur quoi
concrètement le new york times sa maison
[Musique]
de l'élu hartheim ça et beaucoup
d'autres organes de presse aux
etats-unis peine
démenti society sur pertes et toutes les
personnes qui tous les invités qu'il
s'agisse de moi ou quelqu'un d'autre
comme des porte-parole du kremlin
[Musique]
c'est une approche très paraissait c'est
stupide mais c'est là c'est celle qu'ils
prennent ils regardent ce qui se passe
sur rte le dise à telle personne a dit
cela donc cette personne doit s'exprimer
pour le très bien c'est un jeu que le
new york times et d'autres anciennes de
presse et aux etats-unis jouent depuis
très longtemps alors l'un des arguments
de ce papier c'est aussi que vladimir
poutine aurait toujours critiquer les
vaccins alors déjà on se demande quels
rapports effectivement que le
coronavirus et puis est ce une réalité
non ce n'est pas vrai le président
poutine soutient fortement la
vaccination ne serait-ce que récemment
il qu'ils aient avec fierté qu'il prend
le vaccin de la grippe chaque année donc
il n'y a aucun aucune raison de dire que
le président poutine mais contrôlé
vaccination mais certaines personnes à
plusieurs reprises qu'ils ont d'être
invité à sur rte sont très critiques
envers le vaccin et c'est un débat en
cours qu'il y existe aux états unis et
dans d'autres pays portant sur
l'efficacité des vaccins achetés donne
l'occasion de s'exprimer à des personnes
de tous les horizons
cela ne signifie pas que rt cautionne
les positions anti vaccination encore
mois que le kremlin et les cautionnent
alors là on parlait du new york times
maintenant on va parler
de l'état américain qui vise cette fois
ci plus tôt la chine n'en ai pas la
russie les etats-unis qui ne semble pas
exclure que le coronavirus proviennent
en réalité d'un laboratoire chinois a
one et évoquent désormais une enquête
pour faire la lumière sur son origine
emmanuel macron effectivement lui aussi
rebondi indique qu'il ya un flou le
royaume uni 6 mais aussi en disant que
la chine va devoir répondre vladimir
poutine lui juste ses accusations contre
productive qu'est ce qu'on peut retenir
de cette séquence qui semble monter un
dans d'actualité il ya une sorte de
théorie du complot de la une fait aucun
doute ce virus est à paris et le chine
comme un jeu l'opposé jeu là les idées
conventionnelles précédentes c'est que
l'origine de ces virus étaient le marché
devra ne le fasse en 2003 est également
apparu dans ces marchés les autres mais
il est difficile de savoir à ce jour si
c'était effectivement dans ces marchés
qui est apparu le virus du sida été
créés dans un laboratoire
c'est un cas intéressant car
l'anticommunisme et si l'une errant dans
la culture politique de washington
washington est tout à fait prêt à se
saisir de vite et que c'est le parti
communiste chinois qui est coupable de
l'apparition de ce virus
parce que à cause de leurs activités
dans ses laboratoires du manque de
sécurité etc
l'alternative serait de tirs que c'est
mon marché son stade une pratique
barbare et que d'autres que blâmer la
population chinoise
s'agit-il
de blâmer le peuple ou le parti chinois
mais le président poutine a raison ce
n'est vraiment pas le moment de faire
porter le chapeau ou d'accusée déjà en
quarts à quoi cela va-t-il mener en où
l'on à un autre il faudra effectivement
que l'union ne tienne les comptes de ce
qui s'est passé de pourquoi cela s'est
passé car l'économie mondiale accor est
dans l'ornière on ne peut pas continuer
comme cela
il ne faut pas avoir une autre pandémie
une autre crise économique dans cinq à
dix ans donc il sera important
d'explorer les conséquences profondes
merci beaucoup de georges mélies
chercheur au global police in situ
d'avoir été avec nous pour notre
rubrique a vu de l'extérieur ce soir